for our math kids a ton of oblivious
townspeople and a whole lot of hidden
alien during its two decades on TV South
Park has become a cultural institution
but how'd it be unlikely launching
irreverent cartoon make it to air in the
first place
born of boredom music major Trey Parker
and Matt major Matt stone mad in film
class at the University of Colorado in
1992 they found themselves stuck on
other classmates film sets working the
lighting and sound and generally feeling
pretty bored Parker and stone started
doing silly voices to amuse each other
and found they had the same sense of
humor Parker told Entertainment Weekly
we would always talk like these little
kids and make each other laugh they
messed around with the characters for a
full year
before they ever thought to commit
anything to fill a school presentation
before Parker and stone decided to turn
their characters into pop culture icons
Parker made his own cartoon debut with a
satirical school presentation called
American history which used the same
construction paper animation style that
the duo eventually adopted the South
Park
it was the amateur effort that would
launch a thousand f-bombs the cartoon
won a student prize at the University of
Colorado in 1992 inspiring Parker and
stone to take it further knowing that
the film department had a short film
showcase at the end of the year they
decided to do something holiday
appropriate for their December debut so
they made the spirit of Christmas
also known as Jesus versus Frosty which
is exactly what it sounds like in
Minnesota put a hat on a snowman and I'd
try to kill her you're not getting right
yet so they didn't all have names kids
they looked and sounded pretty similar
to Kyle Kenny Stan and common are all
there it even has some pretty familiar
lines oh at the first screening the
audience went not people were shocked
and seeing cute cartoon kids swear up a
blue streak and having Christmas icons
try to murder one another but since it
was a college ground most of the people
loved it
cannibals the musical after Jesus versus
fry
pygar and stone didn't go right to work
on more animated jobs instead they made
a trailer for a musical comedy about
Alfred Packer a man famous for survival
cannibalism in Colorado ah Beng about a
night the University of Colorado which
hilariously named its own cafeteria
after Parker liked the trellis so much
he gave the duo one hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars to shoot a
full-length feature they weren't
completely ready to leave snowman behind
though the resulting cannibal the
musical was a glimpse into Parker and
stones future with Henson's the demented
comedy and budding musical genius they
would find its way into their
professional projects years later and
believe it or not they even hit a few
aliens throughout the film like they
would later in South Park Troma
productions picked up the filter
distribution three years after it was
made Brian Graydon at the Fox
Broadcasting Company happened to see it
and he immediately wanted to work with
Parker and Stine so he couldn't get any
major studio to take a liking to
cannibals Graydon was determined to make
something happen with the path the
Christmas card and Clooney as great in
Parker and stone were trying to get
something off the ground including a
failed children's TV show pilot called
Cohn walked Parker and stone were
hurting for cash grading gave them
$1,200 to make a video Christmas card
based on the original Jesus versus
frosty short thinking it would only be
seen by a few of his friends Parker and
stone were excited to get money to do
anything so they made a new five minute
short and figured it would be the last
time they visit the quiet little
mountain town the spirit of Christmas
also known as Jesus versus Santa was
even more similar to the soon-to-be
South Park than the original though the
short had many future South Park staples
Parker and stone didn't even put their
names on the film cos they figured it
was just a little project for fun
Grayden ended up sending the tape around
to about 35 friends but he purposely
didn't send it to any studio head
assuming the material would offend
but the people who actually saw Jesus
versus desert love the shorts so much
they copied it sent it to their friends
and showed it at parties one of the
biggest fans of the short was George
Clooney South Park executive producer
and Garifuna told Hollywood Reporter
before we even began working on the
series the fact that George Clooney had
made hundreds of VHS copies of the
spirit of Christmas and sent them out to
all his friends was already the stuff of
Hollywood history without Clooney
sharing hundreds of bootleg VHS tapes
South Park might never have happened
rejection despite other people claiming
to have created the popular but
anonymous sure Parker and stone
eventually got the credit they deserved
and offers began coming their way
including the chance to direct Barney's
great adventure which obviously they did
not take Graydon Parker and stone got
meetings everywhere but nearly all of
the studios were afraid of putting
something so edgy on the air and there
was also the assumption that every show
needed to go The Simpsons were out and
depict a family not a bunch of nasty
kids they were turned down by MTV and
graded was even turned down by his own
Network Fox so great and left the
company to go where ever South Park
landed Comedy Central wasn't afraid of
the potty-mouth tots and signed them on
to make a pilot the crashed pilot when
Parker and stone got to bring South Park
to life they didn't pull any punches the
first episode Cartman gets an anal probe
was shown two focus groups where people
would rate the show on a scale of one to
ten the show hardly got anything over a
three and there were lots of the ones
three people actually cried because they
were so disturbed over the things the
children said or did Comedy Central
didn't pull the plug on the series
altogether though there were a
struggling Network at the time and add a
slightly modified pilot mostly because
they knew it would get them attention
every few years a family show comes
along that captures America story
and Comedy Central's new show South Park
to that little South Park debuted in
August 1997 after minimal promotion
graden thought they'd be lucky to get
200,000 people to tune in
but the premiere got 889 thousand
viewers and the show is pulling in over
5 million by the end of the season it
was an instant insane hit before long
the show was on the cover of Rolling
Stone and Newsweek Cartman eternal
despite the remarkable success Parker
and stone didn't think they'd be working
on it for very long at all
Parker recalled to The Hollywood
Reporter we thought it's not going to
last take a while you can we really had
the attitude of let's do this as long as
we can then we'll go back to Colorado he
went on to say that it wasn't until
around season 15 of the show that he
realized they'd probably never need to
go back home thanks for watching click
the blue icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to